autres barques autre nouveauté depuis le
2 avril le parc zoologique de thoiry
invite ses visiteurs à découvrir son
labyrinthe sous un autre jour les 6000
mètres carrés de son parcours sont
dorénavant le théâtre d'une mission pour
aider et sauver les animaux on y tourne
on y trouve 15 animaux fantastiques
protégées dont 4 animatronics écouter
collombat de lapanouse directrice
générale déléguée du parc qui a conçu
cette animation
en fait on a un jeune biologiste qui
s'appelle no et lui veut sauver les
espèces menacées et son petit frère fu
fu lui il a créé plein de d'animaux
extraordinaires qui n'existe pas et il
les a mélangé avec les animaux du zoo
donc la mission c'est d'aider nos et à
remettre de l'ordre dans tout ça parce
que maintenant c'est tout mélanger et
c'est vraiment n'importe quoi